ce par tous s'il arrive quelque chose
tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
court 1h30 d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenus à bonne distance
évidemment et nos reporters une émission
essentiellement consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus en france et dans le monde
voici les titres le port du masque
anti-projections doit être généralisé
dans l'espace public recommandations de
l'académie de médecine qui appelle les
français à s'équiper dès maintenant sans
attendre le début du déconfinement les
ministres ont d'ailleurs remis leurs
plans secteur par secteur pour se dé
confiner le déficit de la sécu lui
plonge à 41 milliards d'euros du jamais
vu selon gérald darmanin
[Musique]
la gestion de la crise sanitaire dans
les pays développés pointé du doigt par
le professeur à août selon
l'infectiologue les pays riches sont
paradoxalement moins prêts à l'arrivée
de nouvelles maladies que les pays
pauvres
les 15 pays qui ont la plus forte
mortalité ne sont que des pays riches
selon lui l'excès de précaution de la
réglementation sont elles des entraves à
la gestion de la crise en france ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à 20h15 le
virus va t'il nous accompagner pendant
longtemps encore selon l' oms ce sera
oui on europe l'espagne connaît un
deuxième rebond d'affilée du nombre de
décès du co beat 19 au royaume uni selon
une estimation aujourd'hui du financial
times le bilan sera deux fois supérieure
aux 18 1100 morts annoncé par londres
dans le monde un pays fait figure
d'exemple le vietnam ont aucun décès n'a
été constaté
après la france autre ans
la france au 37e jours de confinement
les ministres auront donc leur premier
projet de déconfinement alors qu
emmanuel macron s'est déplacé en
bretagne a pour rendre visite à ceux qui
sont en deuxième ligne
le chef de l'état s'est rendu dans une
exploitation agricole à cléder dans le
nord finistère
il a également rencontré le personnel
d'un supermarché à saint pol de léon
objectif remercier la ferme france et
soutenir le monde agricole en proie à
l'inquiétude et qui estiment ne pas être
assez rémunérés le président de la
république qui est arrivé sur les
exploitations sans masque mais s'est
tenue à bonne distance des maraîchers au
moment même où l'académie nationale de
médecine préconise dès aujourd'hui le
port obligatoire du masque dans l'espace
public
emmanuel macron qui a également évoqué
un déconfinement modulée par secteur et
par région alors visite opportune ou
coûte communication pour en parler nous
sommes en direct avec alexis poulain
cofondateur du monde moderne
un bon soir alexis à poulain merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
emmanuel macron sur le terrain donc à la
rencontre des agriculteurs et des
acteurs de la distribution
à votre avis est-ce que c'est ce qu'a
t-on de lui les français en ce moment
non les français attendent un plan de
déconfinement clair ils attendent des
masques qu'ils attendent des tests ils
attendent au delà des dates annoncées de
savoir si les enfants qu'ils vont
remettre à l'école vont être protégé les
professeurs attendent de savoir s'ils
vont être protégé ils attendent des
mesures concrètes et pas une
communication d'ordre personnel qui a du
mal à cacher en fait le fait que le plan
de déconfinement n'est pas prêt comme
vous lisiez c'est au cas par cas les
ministres sont en train de présenter les
copies mais on voit bien que on ne sait
pas vraiment où on va et je crois pas
que c'est la place des mails macron que
d'aller faire le touriste au sein de son
propre pays pour aller voir les gens qui
sont comme il le dit en deuxième ligne
qui font tourner la boutique
il a peut-être autre chose à faire
notamment pour accélérer la livraison de
ces masques savoir où est ce qu'on va se
les procurer rendez vous compte on est
toujours dans le flou le plus complet
comment
on va avoir ses masques est ce qu'on va
les acheter ce qu'ils vont être
distribués par la pause par les
pharmacies voilà toutes ces questions là
qui demain en suspens ça ne sert à rien
de se mettre en scène avec les
travailleurs et les travailleuses pour
dire qu'il est au fond comme il aime à
le croire je crois que c'est une
communication politique délétère alors
emmanuel macron à vous en parliez de ces
masques alexis poulain emmanuel macron
justement sans masque mais à bonne
distance en des personnes qu'il a
rencontrées des maraîchers au moment
même où l'académie de médecine rendrai
selon elle obligatoire le port du masque
quel signal envoie le président eh bien
ces communications communications
communication rappelez vous il ya
quelques semaines de ça quand il va à
mulhouse son premier déplacement aussi
la porte parole du gouvernement de ciba
thénia guillemets emmanuel macron n'a
pas besoin de marque parce qu'ils ne
respectent les mesures les gestes
barrières et on le voit apparaître sur
les écrans de télévision avec un masque
et puis là comme il faut gérer la
pénurie et ne pas avoir de masse parce
que les français se dirait mais alors
qui a droit aux masques certains thèmes
personnes auraient drogba ce n'est pas
tout le monde donc il n'y avait pas de
match pour dire mais c'est pas grave on
va se débrouiller avec les gestes
barrières parce qu'il n'ya pas de masque
parce qu'ils ne sont toujours pas là
rendez vous compte dimanche soir la
conférence de presse de l'événement et
de d'edouard philippe voilà ce que dit
le ministre de la santé et des
solidarités
les masques vous les verrez bientôt pas
de date pas de plan et donc emmanuel
macron qu'est-ce qu'il fait bien il se
met en scène sans masse pour dire c'est
pas grave on peut sortir dehors sans
masque regarder je le fais et du moment
qu'on reste à un mètre de distance
eh bien ça ne pose aucun problème c'est
de la pure communication et c'est pas
forcément la meilleure
alors un sondage aujourd'hui intéressant
l'hebdomadaire harris interactive
on va le voir ensemble et lexie poulain
moins d'un français sur deux en fait
désormais confiance au gouvernement pour
prendre des mesures efficaces pour
mettre fin à l'épidémie 57% vous le
voyez à l'écran des personnes
interrogées ont le sentiment que le
gouvernement n'a pas pris des mesures
assez importante depuis le début de la
crise
en revanche ça va un petit peu mieux sur
la confiance du gouvernement pour
prendre des mesures efficaces en matière
économique 1 53%
des français satisfaits à ce niveau là
contrairement effectivement la gestion
de la crise selon vous alexis poulain
que reprochent les français à l'exécutif
dans cette lutte contre locaux vides
mais il reproche je lui avais déjà dit à
cet enfer ils reprochent les mensonges
répétés les à-peu-près le fait de ne pas
savoir en fait ce qu'il se passe ne pas
savoir ce qui est prévu le flou
artistique entretenu c'est à dire que à
quoi ça sert de se mettre en scène de
parler si on n'apporte pas des mesures
concrètes pourquoi es tu vois la tour
des municipales aussi peut-être
évidemment ce premier tour pourquoi
l'avoir se sachant qu'on n'allait
confiner le lendemain des municipales
avec le lourd tribut qu'on payait les
élus pour avoir tenu ce premier tour
parce que ils ont fait confiance à la
parole du gouvernement de la confiance
est rompue mais mais depuis longtemps et
ça n'a fait qu'empirer avec les
mensonges répétés
rappelez vous il n'y a pas de pénurie de
masques c'était les paroles de monsieur
salomon agnès buzyn lorsqu'elle était
ministre également disait qu'il n'y
avait aucun problème qu'on avait les
stocks qu'il fallait tout était dans de
bonnes mains oliveira quand il prend les
commandes du ministère de la santé remet
une couche en disant que tout va très
bien madame la marquise or non ça ne va
pas on gère une pénurie et les
françaises demandent on leur a fait
croire alors que la france était une
grande puissance mondiale et ce ne
serait pas le cas non visiblement non
puisque ça fonctionne parce qu'il ya des
soignants qui travaillent qui sont en
première ligne
aussi des personnels roulants de la sncf
qui font des trains sanitaire qui
permettent de désengorger les régions
tous ces gens là et bien il ne demande
rien ils travaillent ils font tourner la
machine pendant que ce qui devrait être
stratège ceux qui devraient planifier le
déconfinement eh bien on les voit douter
ne pas savoir et gérer une pénurie sans
pouvoir mettre les mots sur cette paix
nous remercie beaucoup alexis poplin
d'avoir été avec nous avoir apporté
votre analyse et la france qui déplore
plus de 21000 décès
lié aux coronavirus annonce comme chaque
soir en du directeur général de la santé
jerôme seine au monde c'était il ya
quelques minutes le solde d'admissions à
l'hôpital demeure négatif avec 365
personnes hospitalisées en moins par
rapport à hier
le nombre de personnes en réanimation
baisse lui aussi pour le quatorzième
jour consécutif ce soir
les remontées de 1311 établissements de
santé confirme que 21,9 29 mille pardons
sept cent quarante et une personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisées pour
infection que 8,19 1619 nouveaux
patients ont été admis au cours des
dernières 24 heures mais en tenant
compte des sorties qui sont nombreuses
le solde reste négatif avec 365
personnes hospitalisées en moins par
rapport à hier 5218 patients atteints
par l'affection que vides sont dans un
état grave en réanimation au cours des
dernières 24 heures 180 3 nouveaux
malades graves ont été admis en
réanimation
le solde reste négatif depuis maintenant
deux semaines
il est de 215 patients en moins en
réanimation
enfin nous surveillons de près la
mortalité mortalité hospitalière la
mortalité en institution et évidemment
la mortalité générale sur le territoire
français en ce qui concerne la mortalité
hospitalière nous déplorons 13200 36
décès depuis le 1er mars 80 2 % de ces
décès sont survenus chez des personnes
de plus de 70 ans et nous déplorons
aussi 32 décès outremer dans les
établissements sociaux et médico-sociaux
8104 décès ont été relevées depuis le
début de l'épidémie le 1er mars
et l'essentiel de ces décès est observée
en ehpad et pour l' oms le virus va nous
accompagner encore longtemps le
professeur didier raoult lui ne sont pas
de cet avis il persiste et signe pour
lui l'épidémie ne saurait que ces eaux
hier est sur le point même de se
terminer j'ose dire on aimerait bien le
croire écoutez écoutez le dans cette
dernière vidéo publiée hier sur la
chaîne youtube de l'institut de
méditerranée t on à une diminution
maintenant constante du nombre de cas
diagnostiqués au cinéma de quartier tel
hervé animations le nombre de morts sera
un peu plus long parce que les gens
meurent souvent plus d'un mois après
avoir été infectés donc tout ça pas
exactement le même rythme on a les mêmes
données dans la région paca plus ou
moins décalé on a les mêmes données en
france on a même donné dans la plupart
des pays d'europe même donné en amérique
du nord donc on est sur une vague
descendante
quand je vois moi je prédis pas l'avenir
si les choses continuent comme ça on a
bien l'impression que ce qui était une
des possibilités de cette maladie
s'avère une maladie saisonnière est en
train de se réaliser et que les
possibles que dans d'ici un mois et +24
du tout par des pays tempérés
donc c'est possible c'est une des
possibilités qui n'est pas négligeable
et qui va amener à une vraie réflexion
une réflexion de fond qui suscite des
débats d'une intensité et d'une violence
que je jamais soupçonnée et pâques ici
ici mais dans le monde on a des
réactions très violentes qui montre que
l'arrivée d'une maladie nouvelle aiguë
et quelque chose à quoi l'ensemble des
pays riches n'est pas prête et dans
cette nouvelle vidéo de liège suis
méditerranée didier rahout livre donc
une analyse assez personnelle de
l'épidémie coronavirus les pays riches
auraient plus de mal selon lui à mener
la guerre contre l'épidémie la france
est particulièrement visée
selon lui les grands labos
pharmaceutiques en profiteraient
directement quand on voit maladies comme
celle là le temps qu'il faut pour
traiter ça est très court est ce que on
doit traiter cette maladie
ou est ce qu'on doit faire des essais
donc nous on a fait le choix de traiter
la maladie on a eu la réaction d'une
violence inouïe mais on n'avait pas le
choix si l'on voulait traiter cette
maladie il fallait prendre ce qui était
disponible ce qui était logique c'est à
dire des médicaments qui montre contre
le virus qui marche contre le virus qui
sont les médicaments les plus utilisés
du monde les plus les moins dangereux du
monde et ça a levé les grandes folies de
trouver que le médicament le plus
prescrit l'histoire de l'humanité était
un médicament dangereux si on sait
comment tout ça sort l'étude qui a été
fait sur un million de personnes qui
prennent ça pour une polyarthrite
rhumatoïde il pas deux il n'ya pas
d'inconvénient sauf après deux ou trois
ans on commence à avoir des problèmes
oculaires mais pendant dix jours c'est
inimaginable l'astronomie since est le
traitement le plus utile
mon grand tibet tic par les affections
respiratoires tout ça tout ça de prendre
de médicaments aussi simple que ça pour
traiter quelque chose qui est une
colonie ça tombe sous le sens sauf si on
veut pas les traiter en attendant
d'avoir des essais pour voir si on peut
avoir des molécules est la lutte contre
le corona virus entravée par la
méthodologie des pays les plus riches la
mortalité dans ses grandes heures ces
grandes puissances pousse-t-elle en
effet à s'interroger alors peut-on
vraiment arrivé à la même conclusion le
professeur de marseille c'est l'objet de
notre face à face et pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec patrick
mennucci conseiller municipal ps de la
ville de marseille bonsoir patrick
mennucci merci d'être avec ces à ses
côtés à distance bien évidemment jean
philippe delsol avocats fiscalistes et
président de l'institut de recherches
économiques et sociales bonsoir à vous
aussi
alors ce qu'on sera soulevée par le
professeur out les pays riches qui
auraient plus de mal à mener la guerre
contre le virus hin1 et précise le
professeur pour étayer son propos que
dans 15 pays qui ont la plus forte
mortalité
ce ne sont en fait que les pays riches
que vous inspire ce constat vous on
commence par vous patrick mennucci août
et je sais que on entend beaucoup de
choses sur tous ces sujets moi je crois
que les pays riches sont souvent les
pays démocratiques etc que dans les pays
démocratiques il est plus compliqué de
lutter contre les virus en bavière les
pays où elle a le sens de la démocratie
n'est pas exactement le même que chez
nous qui peuvent imposer des choses qui
sont difficiles pour les gouverneurs
france et des pays européens imposé donc
pour l'instant je crois qu'on entend
beaucoup de choses moi j'ai plutôt j'ai
toujours eu de très grande confiance
dans la science et j'avoue que je suis
un peu déboussolée d'entendre à longueur
deux chaînes de télévision et de radio
des médecins se contredire sur ce sujet
c'est extrêmement inquiétant il faut
bien comprendre et vous vous jeu parce
que vous êtes tous les uns et les autres
dans ma situation on aimerait avoir
beaucoup plus de certitudes que nous
avons malheureusement nous n'avons pas
et donc nous sommes amenés à suivre les
directives du gouvernement et notamment
la question du comme fille de ron qui a
quand même permis de limiter la pomme
débit en france
peut-être parce que malheureusement nous
ne savons pas grand chose sur cette
épidémie
jean-philippe delsol vous ce constat
pour revenir au postulat de départ les
pays riches qui auraient plus de mal à
amener la guerre contre le virus patrick
mennucci nous dit plus compliqué
toujours d'imposer des choses dans des
démocraties vous partager ce constat en
partie je pense que si on prend
l'exemple qu'ils aient beaucoup donné en
ce moment du vietnam par exemple
j'aurais deux observations
la première c'est que c'est un pays
encore très communiste et donc tout ce
qu'on nous dit dessus il faut s'en
méfier parce que on l'a bien vu avec la
chine mais comme l'islande par
définition donc prudence
jean blanc garde totalement la
responsabilité mais enfin l'exemple
chinois est là pour le démontrer
deuxième observation dans un pays qui
est une prison comme le vietnam elle est
encore en partie bien entendu c'est plus
facile de dire à chacun de rester dans
sa cellule et c'est là que je rejoint
d'une certaine manière ce que disait
patrick mennucci mais avec des dés
propos peut-être un peu plus vif et plus
illustres et j'en conviens je crois que
d'une manière plus générale il est sans
doute difficile de tirer des conclusions
aujourd'hui oui peut-être que par
exemple aux états unis on aura plus de
morts parce qu'à plus de base c'est très
possible
c'est l'une des options mais je crois
qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin
aujourd'hui
alors tu as écouté avant de faire réagir
patrick mennucci didier raoul qui était
un petit peu son son propos justement il
évoque le traitement de la maladie
dans les pays riches écouter tous les
pays riches et tous les pays développés
ont eu des succès beaucoup moins
important que les pays pauvres qui est
assez raisonnablement ont choisi de
traiter ça comme une pneumonie avec des
médicaments banale qui nous coûte rien
et tuant du coût des mortalités beaucoup
plus faible et dans les 15 pays qui ont
la plus forte mortalité ça n'est que des
pays riches
on sait déjà qu'il ya une déconnexion
actuellement entre la richesse et la
capacité à répondre à des situations de
cet ordre là moi peut-être que j'ai été
capable d'y répondre parce que je suis
en partie africain donc c'est une partie
de mes origines qui me laisse l'idée que
l'on doit traiter les maladies
infectieuses
alors on va essayer de décortiquer ces
propos mais en clair c'est ce qu'il
disait tout à l'heure on l'entendait
dans le son précédent en gros ils vont
droit au but
ils prennent voilà des traitements qui
existe déjà
alors que les pays plus industrialisés
souffrent et peut-être de trop de
réglementation de trop peut-être de
précaution patrick mennucci a un petit
peu du but vrai
l'industrie je voudrais d'abord préciser
que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le
professeur houle parce qu'en plus
dans les moments que nous vivons mais il
a soigné avec succès ma vieille tante et
je lui en suis très reconnaissant de
l'avoir fait à 10 h u à marseille et je
crois qu'il ya effectivement avec
beaucoup d'humanité traiter tous les
marseillais qui ont dû être hospitalisé
à la timone
je suis pardonnez moi de vous couper
mais mais votre expérience parle ça veut
dire qu il la traitait avec deux lacs
laurent totalement décor rétro dans les
détails familiaux mais c'est une
personne de 81 10 heures l'actuel de ma
mère qui elle est décédée et évidemment
pourquoi insister auprès de l'ap-hm pour
cuillé les hospitalisations parce que il
y avait tendance à ne pas hospitaliser
personnes trop âgées ce qui est
scandaleux qu'un délit sommes
disponibles pour les régler cette
question et elle a été traitée
effectivement al ahli bank ci pourrait
qu'il est
voilà le salé sortie avec vous jean
pauly négative j'espère que ça va durer
comme vous le savez c'est une maladie
extrêmement complexe et donc on peut pas
tout dire parce que je voulais revenir à
votre question je disais ça parce que je
veux qu'on comprenne aussi eu il ya
aussi les sentiments humains qui sont
dans ces affaires-là puisqu'on est dans
une pandémie il ya des morts et il ya
donc bien des des histoires personnelles
qui sont celles d oeil des autres et de
ce qu'y que vous recevez du sur ses
plateaux qui ont une vie aussi par
ailleurs et moi ce que je crois le pied
dans ce que dit didier holt séguin que
les pays dont il parle et je suis
d'accord avec monsieur del sol se sauve
les pays qui ne disent pas la vérité sur
la situation soit qu'ils ne le disent
pas pour des raisons politiques par les
viêt nam partage ce qui vient d'être dit
sur la nature du régime ou la chine
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus ou qui
n'ont pas les moyens scientifiques de
faire les recoupements et de données et
des statistiques anthony tel pays je
n'incite ok mais africains auraient
moins deux morts un pourcentage que la
femme c'est l'italie l'espagne ou
l'amérique je serais quand même curieux
de connaître les protocoles
scientifiques de l'addition des
personnes qui ont été atteintes
est ce que c'est si c'était le coroner
voilà je crois qu'il ya des biais nous
devons être extrêmement prudent et je
crois que si on veut être honnête avec
ce que nous savons est ce que nous
sommes
il faut être très humble d'indre des
affirmations d'une bombe alors jean
philippe delsol rebondissement ce que
disait patrick mennucci m'enfin au
moment où on dit ça faudrait que le
financial times lui accuse les autorités
britanniques
en tout cas pas accuse mais en tout cas
dit que le bilan est largement
sous-estimé le financiel times pense
qu'il y a deux fois plus de morts donc
c'est la panacée également des
démocraties peut-être de ce jeu met des
guillemets trompé sur les bilans liés
aux coronavirus à ce qui est vrai c'est
que le gouvernement de monsieur macron
nous a trompés pendant un moment en nous
donnant un nombre de morts chaque jour
qu'ils n'étaient que le nombre de morts
en hôpital
donc effectivement c'était très trompeur
bon ceci dit les choses ont été
rétablies je ne veux pas les accuser
d'avoir fait ça totalement sciemment ils
l'ont fait dans la précipitation
pour en revenir à votre sujet je pense
qu'ils voulaient que normalement c'est
vrai que les pays pauvres ont moins de
moyens
ils ont des techniques plus
rudimentaires ils ont moins d'argent ils
devraient donc avoir plus de difficulté
à combattre une épidémie d'autant que ce
sont souvent des pays chauds pas
toujours mais pas souvent dans
lesquelles les gens vivent plus grande
promiscuité et
donc on se pose cette question vous nous
avez posé pourquoi est ce que semble que
lille les pays riches
au contraire on plus de personnes
frappées pâle il est vraisemblable et là
je rejoins didier raoul
il est vraisemblable que si nous n'avons
pas su donner une bonne réponse très
rapide
en dépit des moyens de la richesse etc
nous avons dû développement qui est le
nôtre c'est probablement parce que nous
devenons un peu comme les dinosaures
vous savez on dit que les dinosaures
sont morts parce que il était devenu
tellement grand tellement gros que quand
un serpent mortels les piquets à la
queue il n'avait pas le temps de réagir
parce que la tête ne le comprenez que
trop tard et est en fait les pays riches
beaucoup d'enfants en tout cas et
notamment les les pays centralisé comme
la france mais pas que la france
d'ailleurs
et les pays qui n'ont pas acquis qu'ils
sont réservés à l'égard de l'économie de
marché c'est à dire aller cas à l'égard
de l'économie privée
ces pays là sont des pays qui en fait
pense que la seule solution c'est l'état
et c'est la centralisation et d'ailleurs
je me souviens que monsieur mac rôle le
20 21 ou 22 mars ça le jour où il a
annoncé le confinement
il nous a dit ah mais regardez c'était
son discours là enfin on comprend que on
a la chance d'avoir un état fort et d'un
état qui fait tout et bien justement on
s'est aperçu qu'on avait la malchance
d'avoir un état trop fort et d'un état
qu'ils faisaient trop en fait
l'état ne sait pas tout faire il faut
qu'ils sachent qui éventuellement
coordonnées éventuellement s'assurer que
les choses sont faites 6 et les limites
mais ça n'est pas à lui de tout faire
quand il veut tout faire il fait mal
la preuve c'est que en fait il n'a
compté au départ et on a pris beaucoup
de retard au départ pourquoi parce qu'il
n'a compté que sur l'hôpital public les
les hôpitaux privés associatifs souvent
les cliniques privées
oh c'est très vilain des cliniques
privées il ya des capitaux privés vous
rendez compte ce que ces vilains
méchants
forcément c'est des gens qui ne pensent
pas à la santé des gens ils pensent
qu'on profite
ben non et en fait c'est une mauvaise
réaction est donc en ne comptant que sur
le pied d'un public en refusant l'aide
des autres
tv qui avait beaucoup de lits de
réanimation offert pour accueillir des
patients et qu'on refusait on a préféré
faire venir l'armée allait en allemagne
en autriche ou en suisse pour y apporter
des malades alors qu'ils avaient des
lits vides délit qui attendaient des
patients vous voyez un exemple du
scandale français de l'étape trop fort
de l'état obèses ont dit que les obèses
attrape plus facilement le virus et bien
je crois que l'état centralisé trop
important il attrape trop facilement le
virus de la puissance est manifestement
il y à là chez nous un état malade de ce
virus de la puissante
après je crois que c'est ça a été la
difficulté que rencontre d'un reconnu
cette difficulté à réagir
on est en train de rattraper parce qu'à
la fin on a des gens intelligents
on a eu la chance d'avoir un personnel
extrêmement dévoués dans les
établissements sanitaires qui a compensé
un peu les défauts du système mais je
crois qu'il faudra en retenir la leçon
patrick mennucci la réponse fut
rapidement s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce
qu'on arrive malheureusement la fin de
sa vie mais je pense que mettre des sols
utilisés dans un environnement qui suit
pandémie et qui poursuit dans cet
environnement de la pandémie ses
positions politiques que nous lui
connaissons depuis 40 ans donc il essaie
de démontrer que c'est parce que les
tailles propre réserve que nous avons
des difficultés
moi je suis plus modérée je crois que il
ya des erreurs qui ont été faites que
ces erreurs on les combat en a c'est le
manque de masquer ses erreurs
d'anticipation mais que quand même
globalement les décisions qui ont été
prises par l'état et notamment par le
service dans les services hospitaliers
alors moi je suis absolument pas
d'accord avec m del sol quand il dit
qu'il aurait mieux valu mettre des
malades d'armes les dans des cliniques
privées plutôt que de les envoyer en
allemagne salez
je connais bière et les élus de mulhouse
et je peux dire que les jeunes qui ont
été en moyenne allemagne il ne pouvait
pas aller ailleurs que dame d abord
extrêmement pointues on pouvait sauver
des réseaux rites et on était dans la
plupart vous avez été pour la plupart
d'ailleurs heureusement pour eux grâce à
dieu peut tenir sauver le monde finit
pas ce qu'il faut faire attention
la pandémie sera l'occasion pour
beaucoup d'idéologues comme les monsieur
dancehall mais ce n'est pas une critique
c'est une constatation d'utiliser la
pandémie pour justifier leur position
politique moi je suis beaucoup plus
pragmatique et j'essaye d'être plus
ouvert aux coureurs qui se dit s'exprime
parce qu'il y aura un après et je ne
crois pas que cet après- soit écrit dans
le libéralisme et on en reparlera
ensemble merci en tout cas tous les deux
patrick mennucci jean-philippe delsol
d'avoir un pardon ça ne paraît pas
correct que vous ne laissez pas 30
secondes
oui alors je suis désolé malheureusement
voilà c'est on arrive à la fin il y est
voilà on est je le très court je vous
promets que vous aurez l'occasion de
répondre
voilà vous avez répondu il vous a
répondu aussi non non finis fait on
arrive malheureusement on a des
contraintes antenne ça serait pareil sur
une autre chaîne gens exactement avec le
plaisir c'est une promesse contiendra
puisqu'on arrive malheureusement la fin
on a des timings voilà c'est ainsi
malheureusement
merci en tout cas jean philippe delson
et patrick mennucci portez vous bien
tous les deux aussi voilà et on
continuera ce débat c'est promis merci
est resté avec nous vous parlerons de
l'italie dans quelques instants en
manque de bras le pays pourrait-il
infléchir sa politique migratoire en
raison de l'épidémie puis direction le
royaume uni où le bilan duo kobe de
serait deux fois plus lourd selon le
financiel times
[Musique]
vous vous dites que ce délit de
violation du confinement n'est pas
conforme à la constitution comme ceux
des comptes revient à 1 ou un 2
principes majeurs sont celui du principe
d'égalité des élites et des ailes et le
principe de première nécessité qu'est ce
qu'une femme idéale impérieux j'ai
finalement délaissé à la libre
appréciation de l'agent et ça ne nous
prémunit pas contre un disque
d'arbitrage et son partenaire déclaré
qu'il ne dit pas qu'il y ait des
terreurs et c'est parce que je ne
doutais pas qu'il y aurait des erreurs
et j'ai veillé à ce que le délai des
pompes des stations et et c'est là où la
présomption d'innocence n'est pas
respectable d'état un problème
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre 20h30 en direct
sur rt france cette deuxième partie
consacrée
encore une fois la crise du coronavirus
dans le monde à l'italie qui passe le
cap des 25 mille morts tout le monde
agricole est particulièrement touché par
la crise le secteur souffre d'un manque
de main-d'oeuvre résultat les récoltes
sont menacés alors pour aider ces
agriculteurs près de 200000 sans papiers
devraient être régularisés il aurait
alors la possibilité d'obtenir un
contrat de travail dans la filière
agricole ce serait la plus importante
régularisation depuis plus d'une
décennie dans le pays et pour en parler
nous sommes avec olivier bonnel
journaliste bonsoir olivier bonnel merci
d'être avec nous cette possibilité de
régularisation de 200 milles sans
papiers on nous aurait dit cela il ya
encore quelques mois
d'envisager cette solution ne l'aurais
pas cru est ce que la crise sanitaire
clairement est-elle en train d'
infléchir la politique migratoire
italienne alors c'était un petit peu tôt
pour en parler ce soir mais toujours est
il que 200 milles ce ça correspond à un
chiffre est même très important ça
correspond surtout justement au manque
de main d'oeuvre dans la filière
agricole italienne vous l'avez dit une
filière qui ne fonctionne qui fonctionne
en large partie grâce à ces travailleurs
immigrés alors beaucoup viennent
d'afrique beaucoup viennent aussi des
pays j'ai c'est le gouvernement italien
il est en train de travailler un décret
justement pour régulariser 200 milles
sans papiers c'est un décret qui est en
train d'enquêter à l'étude qui devrait
exister dans l'est dans les prochains
jours du ministère de l'intérieur du
ministère du travail et du ministère de
l'agriculture
parce que aujourd'hui sur les tables des
italiens on a besoin de fruits de
légumes et que souvent ces fruits et
légumes sont récoltées par ces
populations de migrants est le cas
échéant qu'elle pourrait être selon vous
la réaction des italiens on les a vus
plutôt remonté en sur cette question il
est encore quelques mois quand on
connaît la situation des frontières
comme lampedusa
quelles pourraient être les réactions à
ce que les états d'esprit on peut être
évolué depuis ce temps là c'est sûr que
la question a toujours été assez
délicate
il est délicat pour deux raisons la
première c'est parce qu'elle a été
instrumentalisé par certains partis
politiques et notamment l'extrême droite
matteo salvini en avait fait un de ces
de ses chevaux de bataille si j'ose dire
aujourd'hui on voit que la ligue le
parti de monsieur salvini comme le parti
fratelli d'italia de giorgia meloni qui
monte dans les sondages est vent debout
contre la possibilité évidemment de
régulariser ces étrangers l'autre
l'autre opinion dont on parle beaucoup
ici c'est qu'on a besoin de cette main
d'oeuvre
cette manoeuvre elle fait partie du
paysage si j'ose dire sociologique de
l'italie notamment dans les régions du
sud la campanie la basilicate et les
pouilles où on récolte beaucoup
justement de fruits et de légumes et
beaucoup d'italiens voit quand même ces
gens d'abord
ils comprennent qu'aujourd'hui on dans
ces temps de crise avec ses pics ionel
ne serait pas forcément inutile de
régulariser ces personnes qu'elle est
aujourd'hui parce qu évidemment crise du
coronavirus oblige on en parle beaucoup
mais quelle est la situation de ces
migrants en italie est ce qu'ils restent
enfermés dans des camps par exemple
allez salut physique 6 depuis de
nombreuses années puisque ces gens n'ont
pas de statut légal pour la majorité
d'entre eux ils vivent en effet dans des
camps que ça soit en calabre vers gioia
tauro ou dans les pouilles comme je le
disais tout à l'heure sont des gens qui
sont vulnérables qui sont souvent
aux mains des mafias locales c'est un
vrai problème depuis des années en
italie à la question du caporal à le
fait que les mafias se servent d'hommes
de main pour employés au noir
c'était personnes là et ces gens là qui
sont en italie qui sont toujours en
italie vivent encore certains dans des
camps ou ailleurs dans les grandes
villes à mendier alors il ya tout un
faisceau évidemment de deux ong
d'associations caritatives qui prennent
soin d'eux tant bien que mal malgré la
difficulté de cette crise sanitaire
il ya quelques semaines début avril il
ya une
une plateforme qui s'est créé de
cranberries pour récolter des fonds pour
ces migrants pour ces travailleurs
saisonniers qui travaillent dans les
champs qui vivent de manière très
difficile merci beaucoup olivier bonnel
journalistes pour évoquer donc la
situation en italie merci + 4 135 morts
en 24 heures l'espagne enregistrent un
deuxième rebond ddc d'affilée plus de
21000 700 victimes au total dans ce pays
qui prolonge le confinement jusqu'au 9
mai mais qui est assoupli les
restrictions dès dimanche pour permettre
aux enfants de moins de 14 ans de sortir
l'espagne troisième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde un reportage à madrid
de francesco gitta avec alexis combat le
silence règne dans la ville de madrid
désormais vivre confiné devenu la norme
en pleine quarantaine le malheur est
venu frapper à la porte de milliers de
familles
le père de javier tient un énième
service funéraire dans le plus grand
cimetière de madrid
la almudena à cause de la pandémie de
coronavirus le nombre d'inhumation a
triplé
ce prêtre est l'un de ceux à qui les
gens s'adressent en premier lieu pour
trouver du réconfort
cependant il admet qu'il ne peut rester
indifférent face à la douleur de ces
personnes il m'est aussi arrivé de
pleurer dans une église et de demander
seigneur pourquoi dors tu que s'est il
passé
à l'autre bout de madrid se trouve le
cimetière sud
le lieu-dit faire mais l'atmosphère
reste la même des familles en deuil des
gens qui essayent de trouver du
réconfort après la mort soudaine d'un
être cher dans cette chapelle
le père russe et louise prix pour les
morts depuis 20 ans
ces derniers temps ses prières sont
devenus plus courtes trop d'enterrement
rossé louise pense que malgré tout le
malheur causés par la pandémie
il y a des choses que les gens peuvent
apprendre en ces temps difficiles à
mener une vie moins heureux quand
ménages rapporté être moins arrogants et
apprécier la vie intérieure plus que
l'année l'extérieur lorsqu'il a du temps
libre
rocé louise prix pour les défunts il
prit également pour ceux qui n'ont pas
pu accompagner leurs proches dans leur
dernier voyage
selon la réglementation en vigueur trois
personnes au maximum peuvent assister
aux funérailles pour éviter toute
infection mais pour le prêtre dans un
moment aussi difficile
un homme a besoin de fois je pense que
nous devons nous donner de l'espoir pour
moi en tant que croyant la source de
l'espoir et dieu pour de nombreuses
familles cette épidémie a constitué une
tragédie dont la douleur ne s'estompera
pas de sitôt plusieurs se demandent
pourquoi cela devrait-il m'arriver
pourquoi maintenant plus 7 159 décès
lors des 20 dernières 24 heures au
royaume uni ce qui porte le total à 18
1100 morts dus coronavirus outre-manche
mais le bilan serait deux fois plus
lourd affirmation aujourd'hui une
'financial times' selon le journal
britannique la pandémie aurait déjà
causé jusqu'à 41 mille décès dans le
pays soit plus doux
bilan officiel qui ne prend en compte
que les personnes décédées dans les
hôpitaux après avoir été testée positive
au commis 19
l'opposition britannique accuse le
gouvernement de lenteur durant cette
crise un schéma se dessine ici nous
avons été lents à entrer en confinement
lent sur les dépistages lent à mettre en
place des équipements de protection mais
maintenant l'en a accepté les offres
d'équipements britannique
le premier secrétaire affirme qu'il ya
une capacité de 40 me teste par jour
cela signifie qu avant-hier sa quarante
mille tests auraient pu être effectuées
mais que seuls 18 mille ont été
réalisées et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis etc secteur avec marc
atban cagna expert en maladies
infectieuses à l'université donc
d'exeter c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir baratte
balkania merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt feront savoir selon le
journal as économique britannique
le bilan sanitaire est largement
sous-estimé cet article fait-il beaucoup
bruit outre-manche grâce cause de
laisser certains cela a suscité est avec
des inquiétudes que nous ayons que nous
aurions trop sous-estimé le nombre des
morts cela ne fait aucun doute
lorsqu'on in deux chances plutôt content
les personnes à l'hôpital au sein de la
communauté honnête et elle n'est nord a
dû à d'autres locales ainsi que au sein
de la communauté et chinois ont fait
hier quand sa tête de la nuit par
rapport aux années précédentes
on a une surmortalité 20 supérieurs à ce
que nous avions en face des années
précédentes
donc effectivement je suis navré de voir
le dire nombreux sont bien plus osé que
les doses officielle pour le moment et
comment l'expliquer parce que on le
rappelle le delta est quand même
extrêmement important selon le journal
ce chiffre s'établirait autour de 41
milles
décès comment l'expliquer selon vous il
faut que nathalie a number of dicks
malheureusement ça temps libre de ces
morts n'ont pas été correctement il faut
un certain temps que le bureau national
des statistiques
questionne le nombre de personnes mortes
au sein de la communauté
de plus certains bseo des coûts liés à
des causes inconnues cela il faut ré
s'agir du corps navires et sur d'autres
causes comme une unité ce ton pas
systématiquement la communauté les
difficile de dire si la mort est
directement liée aux coronavirus 5 dans
de nombreux cas cela ne fait aucun doute
c'est également lieu qu'ont à virus
pensez vous que cette erreur entre nîmes
et c'est comme ça qu'on va l'appeler
soit faite avec l'aval du gouvernement
à donington historic bonnes études ne
faudrait pas vraiment dire qu'il s'agit
d'une erreur mais cela nous montre
effectivement que notre système de
décompte du nombre de cas au sein de
notre communauté est il sain les
hôpitaux ainsi que dans les maisons de
retraite ne serait pas suffisant mais
pas assez précis n'est pas assez rapide
grâce à une nouvelle technologie pouvait
être plus efficace et recueillir des
week-ends de données plus efficace plus
meilleur et nous devons faire mieux
est-ce qu'à l'instar de la france à
aider c'est en maison de retraite sont
comptabilisés au royaume uni les décès
dans les maisons de retraite sont
comptés si
ainsi enregistré mais il ya un délai
saut ils peuvent être comptabilisés
comme une ode mort en raison du grand
âge et on peut tu indiqué que le
coronavirus a contribué à la mort mais
qu'elle ce cas on ne dit pas que c'est
une mort due au corona virus donc il
peut y avoir des sous-estimations en
fonction du certificat de décès le
gouvernement britannique a démenti
mercredi manqué aujourd'hui donc manqué
d'infirmiers un pur à l'hôpital de
campagne géant ouvert récemment à
londres pour faire face à la pandémie
restez donc très peu utilisé et
contraint selon le guardian de refuser
des patients
on sent qu'il ya beaucoup de suspicion
un boris johnson était malade on l'a un
peu épargné mais et beaucoup de
suspicion envers le gouvernement
britannique
oui elle n'imagine si cette liste
seraient tous des a été créé
dans une chance et c'est une nouvelle
expérience il nous attendions à ce que
beaucoup de personnes et besoin de soins
hospitaliers
d'après les d'urgell et les projections
sommes pas certains si les modèles
étaient exactes
donc aurons nous vraiment besoin d'eux
autant de cet hôpital mount eagle la
deuxième le dira pour le moment on ne
veut pas simplement un hôpital
on veut un hôpital avec du personnel
supplémentaire pour gérer l'hôpital en
obligations personnelles ne servent à
rien l'opposition l'opposition briguent
personnel l'opposition britannique
dénonce également les lenteurs du
gouvernement est ce que c'est un
reproche que vous partagez eyefinity et
je suis déçu tous les experts moi ou
d'autres demandent depuis très longtemps
où sont les équipements de protection
personnelle où sont les matériels de
test où sont les personnes avec l'ue
feront les tests nous avons
effectivement l'impression que quatre à
six semaines en paix et gâcher nous
aurions pu nous préparer bien en avance
donc cela est très décevant je dois être
honnête
merci baratin degania expert en maladies
infectieuses d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france depuis le royaume
uni le vietnam salué par l'eau à metz
pour sa gestion de la crise du
coronavirus ce pays de plus de 90
millions d'habitants est d'une
superficie équivalente à la moitié de la
france ne compterait aucun décès et ce
monde sont 68 cas un pays classé 47e au
niveau des puissances mondiales et qui
partage des frontières terrestres avec
la chine
sa stratégie des mesures rapides et
renouvellement strict des personnes
infectées et précisions de françois
ticket vite ch aéroports d'hanoï le 21
janvier
nous sommes deux jours avant le premier
cas recensé dans le pays
et pourtant des caméras thermiques
contrôle déjà la température des
passagers
le symbole d'une prise de conscience
rapide des autorités vietnamiennes à la
mi janvier
dès les premiers cas en chine un comité
de gestion de crise a vu le jour
réunissant ministère médecins et
scientifiques afin d'anticiper
l'expansion du comice 19 une
anticipation qui se traduit par la
fermeture rapide du trafic aérien vers
la chine et des 1300 kilomètres de leur
frontière commune avec pékin
malgré les réticences des autorités
chinoises personnel de soins retraités
et étudiants en médecine
sont réquisitionnés la production de
masques et prioriser et le gouvernement
interdit la réouverture des écoles dès
le 13 février après les vacances du têt
le nouvel an vietnamien le même jour le
vietnam devient d'ailleurs le premier
pays hors chine a imposé une quarantaine
pendant 21 jours
dix mille personnes d'une zone
résidentielle du nord d'hanoï sont
soumises au confinement après la
découverte de cas parmi des travailleurs
revenant de one nous avons installé un
checkpoint à la demande des autorités
nous serons ici en permanence pour
empêcher les gens de sortir en douce
probablement et propager la maladie car
plutôt que de se lancer dans des tests
de masse trop coûteux pour un pays au
faible revenu par habitant
les autorités se sont davantage
concentrées sur l' isolement des
personnes infectées et la recherche de
tous leurs contacts
une surveillance étroite de la
population rendue possible par une
police et un parti communiste
omniprésent dans la société vietnamienne
mais aussi grâce à une population très
respectueuse des consignes invités à
dénoncer publiquement les individus
fautifs emprisonné immédiatement malgré
cela le 1er avril le gouvernement
instaurer un plan d'isolement social
pour 15 jours avec port du masque
obligatoire recommandation de ne pas
sortir de chez soi sauf pour aller
travailler et interdiction de
rassemblement
je pense que la mesure d'isolement
social est nécessaire en ce moment pour
encourager les gens à ne pas sortir pour
des grands rassemblements en particulier
à des fins inutiles comme les loisirs ou
les repas au restaurant et je ne pense
pas qu'en ce moment on ait besoin d'un
confinement de la ville et du pays tout
entier
vendredi dernier les autorités danoises
ont assoupli ce plan tout en le
prolongeant d'une semaine dans certaines
régions jugées à risque un allègement
progressif
si certains commerces ont rouvert ce
n'est pas le cas des bars et restaurants
et le port du masque demeure lui
toujours obligatoire prêts nous sommes
en direct avec claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales dont
soir claude la blanche maison merci
d'être avec nous alors selon vous pour
quelle raison le vietnam at il si peu de
personnes contaminées aux demandes oui
telle est la spécificité du vietnam en
effet je crois que sa spécificité elle
est due à l'histoire à la résilience de
la population et aussi à la capacité de
ce pays d'inventer des solutions très
pragmatique avec des moyens limités
puisque ses moyens sont limités et dont
le fonds peut être d'avoir une stratégie
que l'on pourrait qualifier de low cost
mais de stratégie low cost efficace
l'histoire c'est évidemment 30 années de
guerres plus 20 ans de boycott américain
ça s'est terminé il ya 25 ans et c'est
tout à fait présent dans la mémoire
d'état viennent d'ailleurs le premier
média et amiens a évoqué il ya quelques
semaines
l'offensive du printemps 1968 au cours
de laquelle les les vietnamiens avaient
surpris les américains et leurs alliés
de ses gonds par conséquent on est bien
dans cette logique-là et c'est sans
doute pour cela que dès la première
alerte
le vietnam
c'est mis sur le pied de guerre alors la
première alerte ça a été naturellement
ce qui se passait en chine puisque c'est
le grand voisin et notamment le patient
numéro zéro lorsque en effet un chinois
venant de wall est arrivé au vietnam
le 23 janvier et que il a constaté qu'il
avait des symptômes du corona virus et
que par conséquent on l'a isolé et et
combiné et à partir de ce moment là un
certain nombre de mesures ont été prises
à partir de cette de cette première
d'abord la fermeture des frontières
comme vous l'avait dit dans votre sujet
dès le 1er février
annulation de tous les vols annulation
de tous les visages et puis aussi ce qui
était très important ces fermetures
d'écoles il se trouve que à l'époque on
était à l'époque du nouvel an chinois et
fête du têt comme on dit au vietnam
et bien tout simplement décidé que les
enfants ne rentrerait pas à l'école
après les vacances du têt le nord du
pays
mitoyen de la chine a été mis dans la
halle isolement complet pendant 21 jours
et puis comme nous sommes au vietnam
bien entendu la propagande il y à des
haut parleurs partout dans les villes
dans les villages et bien là servi à
donner les ordres les recommandations du
ministère de la santé
enfin je dirais que le port du masque a
été généralisé très tôt que les
vietnamiens en fabriquer une quantité
importante de masse pour équiper en
effet les 98 millions d'habitants de ce
pays
alors est ce qu'on peut dire comment je
fais donc les vietnamiens ont tout
simplement lancer les grands moyens pour
affronter l'épidémie et qu'on peut
peut-être également évoqué leur
comportement culturel face à ce virus
oui bien sûr alors les gros moyens oui
en matière de confinement matière de
traçage et en matière d'information en
matière de confinement
les vietnamiens voulu faire un exemple
il se trouve qu'il y avait un mannequin
très célèbre qui revenait d'une tournée
en de tout poil février dans les grandes
capitales occidentales
paris berlin londres new york et qui est
arrivé en montrant aussi des symptômes
et qui montraient qu'elles étaient
infectées par le virus
par conséquent elle a été mise en
confinement avec sa famille avec ses
proches et aussi bien entendu toute la
ville dont est ok qu'elle était qu'elle
n'habitait par conséquent cette mesure a
été emblématique la presse en a beaucoup
parlé et à partir de là tous les
étrangers qui revenait au vietnam
leur température été prise puisque
vietnam n'avait pas les moyens de tester
absolument tout le monde quand on
faisait un test de température et s'il y
avait des indications que ne pouvait
être atteint du coronavirus il était
évidemment isolé aignan confinement
c'était le cas notamment de tous les
étudiants vietnamiens qui revenait de
l'étranger et aussi des viêt kiêu des
vietnamiens qui sont émigrés qui
habitent à l'étranger
voilà pour les mesures en plus la police
vietnamienne a été chargé de poursuivre
les gens qui peuvent porter ce qu'ils
disent puisque dans ce cas là il ya
toujours beaucoup de faits news sur les
réseaux sociaux et les gens ont été
condamnés à des amendes assez importants
sur le système de santé qu'en est-il au
vietnam dans ce pays de 200 millions
d'habitants est-ce qu'il est bonne
qualité écoutez moi je veux mon
impression est que et que en effet les
globalement de bonne qualité même si
la partie publique n'a pas toujours les
équipements dernier cri
mais surtout ce qui est beaucoup plus
important c'est que ces médecins sont
très bien formés que beaucoup d'entre
eux ont fait des stages à l'étranger
il se trouve que beaucoup d'entre eux
ont fait des séjours d'une année en
france à la fin des années 90 et au
début des années 2000 plusieurs milliers
de jeunes mais deux jeunes médecins
vietnamiens ont fait fonction d'un dante
interne dans les centres hospitaliers
universitaires français et il se trouve
aussi d'ailleurs que l'institut
d'épidémiologie de hanoi fait partie du
réseau pasteur et que les pasteurien ont
un prestige qui date de l'époque où la
france était présente au vietnam et que
les rues les rues pasteur les rues hier
saint existe à hanoi comme à
hô-chi-minh-ville merci beaucoup claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales
l'amérique latine à présent qui va
connaître selon l'onu la pire récession
de son histoire avec une chute du pib de
5,3 pour cent et sur ce continent
le brésil vie d'une manière particulière
son confinement 600 personnes ont
manifesté dimanche pour réclamer la fin
du confinement parmi eux le président
jaillir vol sonar ou antoine auger pour
les détails
nous ne voulons rien négocier c'est par
ces mots que le président brésilien a
harangué la foule venue réclamer devant
le qg de l'armée
la fin du confinement et une
intervention militaire pour fermer le
parlement et la cour suprême le juge de
la cour suprême fédérale a condamné ces
revendications
selon lui elle porte atteinte à l'état
de droit démocratique du brésil
il a aussi demandé une enquête sur
d'éventuels forme de financement d'actes
anti démocratique
ce lundi jacques bolson araud a répété
qu'il souhaitait que confinement prenne
fin j'espère que c'est la dernière
semaine de quarantaine pour en finir de
cette façon de combattre le virus chacun
chez soi il est impossible que les gens
restent chez eux avec un frigo vide
cette déclaration intervient quatre
jours après le limogeage du ministre de
la santé
luis enrique vendetta favorable
confinement et à la dispensation social
c'est tantôt p10 de profession a irrité
le pouvoir en affirmant sur la chaîne tv
globo que les brésiliens ne savent plus
s'ils doivent écouter le ministre ou le
président mais le successeur de man
d'état
l'oncologue nelson tech ne semble pas
non plus disposé à suivre
aveuglement gerbe also know il a ainsi
déclaré qu'il ne prendrait aucune
décision brusque sur le déconfinement
tout en précisant que le brésil allait
porter le nombre de tests de 24 à 40,6
millions
l'accent dans tout ce que nous allons
faire est mis sur les personnes nous
pouvons parler de santé d'économie peu
importe
en fin de compte nous parlons des gens
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici pour
apporter une meilleure vie à la société
et au peuple brésilien malgré son impact
sur l'économie
68% des habitants approuve le
confinement selon un sondage publié le
18 avril au brésil locaux vides 19
aurait déjà infecté 40000 personnes et
causé la mort de 1500 patients restez
avec nous dans quelques instants la
suite de notre émission nous reviendrons
évidemment sur cette crise du corona
virus en france et ses conséquences
économiques notamment la somme totale
des prêts garantis par l'état accordé
aux entreprises approche des 40
milliards d'euros puis nous partirons
seine maritime
six mois après un incendie de lubrizol
une opération nettoyage a été lancée les
riverains se plaignent d'une rue d'une
odeur nauséabonde
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce vivier un
peu dans la peur avec steam ou ce qui
est des menaces oui d intimidation comme
brûler les locaux oui mais un assassinat
vraiment jeune ans je pense que j'y
croyais pas ceux qui ont été assassinés
étaient les politiques du journal il
était l'âme de ce journal et oui ils ont
tué charlie je voulais pas que tignes où
ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à witty mousse la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
denis rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça faut ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
y'a d'autres experts qui contestent leur
usine l'ordonnancé personnes non non
c'est pas vrai il ya des climats tout
c'est maintenant et non ce n'est pas
rien à part il ya des gens qui ne sont
pas des chercheurs qui parlent que la
presse met en avant parce que il faut
que du débat le ya plus de débat
aujourd'hui
y a plus aucun débat ce changement
climatique et on va vers une vraie
catastrophe va vers une vraie
catastrophe et on est incapable d'en
prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas deux des six mist nous
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons du et les demies il
n'a pas d'ennemi l'ennemi ceni
[Musique]
et
un bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france pour cette demi
heure d'information il est 21h heure de
paris tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité liée à cette crise du
coronavirus sommes près des 40 milliards
d'euros c'est la somme totale des prêts
garantis par l'état annonce du directeur
général de la bpi france une aide plus
que bienvenu pour les entreprises qui
doivent faire face à des problèmes de
trésorerie en cette période de
confinement de six mois frais d'un sans
vie de lusine lubrizol place au grand
nettoyage une opération qui se déroule
en plein confinement grand dam des
riverains et se plaignent ces derniers
jours d'odeurs nauséabondes sur la zone
d'incendié mais aussi de maux de tête ou
de picotement usine elle explique que
l'objectif est justement de réduire ces
émanations
[Musique]
la france déplore dont plus de 21000
décès liés aux coronavirus annonce du
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon en début de soirée le solde
d'admissions à l'hôpital demeure lui
négatif avec 365 personnes hospitalisées
en moins par rapport à hier
le nombre de personnes en réanimation
baisse lui aussi pour le quatrième jour
consécutif
et alors que les ministres ont présenté
à matignon cet après midi une première
mouture de leurs plans sectoriels pour
l'après confinement muriel pénicaud elle
a livré de nouveaux chiffres ce matin un
cap a été franchi plus de 10 millions de
salariés du secteur privé sont anne
présent protégée par le chômage partiel
plus d'un salarié sur deux par ailleurs
des prêts garantis par l'état ont été
accordés aux entreprises qu'aux près de
40 milliards d'euros selon bpi france on
écoute murielle péni ce matin en france
il y a dix millions 200 mille salariés
dont le salaire est payé par l'état par
le ministère du travail mais il ya une
entreprise sur deux qui n'a pas encore
fait sa demande de paiement
il ne suffit pas de dire je vais faire
du chômage partiel il faut faire la
demande de paiement
parce que sinon nous ne savons pas
combien de salaires ont été versés dont
combien on doit rembourser à
l'entreprise
il faut qu'ils fassent leurs demandes et
en sept à dix jours
l'engagement est pris nous remboursons
il avait pour en parler nous sommes avec
charles daawa président l'institut des
libertés bonsoir shales gas charles gave
merci d'être avec nous en direct
dix mille ans et donc au chômage partiel
le chiffres donnent le tournis six
entreprises sur dix touchés en clair
c'est une barre symbolique inquiétante
en bout c'est assez bien entendu ce qui
se passe c'est que vous avez des fonds
propres pour résister à des coups durs
mais la réalité c'est quand votre
chiffre d'affaires disparaît laissant
propres sont insuffisants donc l'idée du
gouvernement de rendre à 2
une partie des salaires ou tu te portes
et des salaires est une bonne idée le
problème c'est que ces résultats auront
pas le problème de fond qui est que la
rentabilité des entreprises françaises
est insuffisant en gros ça veut dire
quoi vous dites c'est une bonne paye et
l'idée de payer mais la rentabilité
n'est pas suffisante qu'elle serait donc
la solution vous envoyer une barre il
faut s'il voulait faire entériner
d'entreprise sans cesse d'augmenter
aujourd'hui les effrayer pour les uns
trop restreint françaises sont quasiment
le le double des frais payés par les
entreprises allemandes ou britanniques
on leur a collé des tricks un exemple
tout ça il ya à peu près aujourd'hui en
france quand quelqu'un est payé il coûte
à son entreprise entre 2 et 2 et demi ce
qu'il a fallu dans le même temps la
france est extrêmement généreuse en ce
moment on vient de le dire
six entreprises sur dix toucher la
moitié des salariés en chômage partiel
c'est très généreux de la part de l'état
pour ses salariés
je veux dire ce que l'état est généreux
c'est toujours une idée un peu
intéressante mais farfelu parce que
l'état ce n'est jamais que le pays andin
pour donc ça veut dire que l'on prend de
l'argent aux baigneurs d'impôt de demain
pour le donner aujourd'hui mais à dire
que l'état est généreux
c'est une plaisanterie de l'état il
produit pas grand jour ce qui fait là
pour l'instant c'est qu'il emprunte de
l'argent que nos petits enfants
rembourseront c'est très bien parce
qu'en effet avant d'être un brin taquin
force majeure mais dire que l'état est
généreux ça ne veut strictement rien
dire puisque l'état c'est vous c'est
nous
je veux pas y a pas quelqu'un qui
s'appelle leila qui créent de la
richesse et des billets s'est pas
l'oncle picsou avec son tas d'or c'est
l'état c'est une abstraction qui est
censé nous gérer mais certainement pas
de créer de la richesse
vous avez l'assurance aujourd'hui enfin
vous en êtes convaincu en tout cas que
nécessairement qui va payer à la fin ce
sera nous via l'impôt où il y aura
peut-être d'autres solutions
privilégiées par le gouvernement sait
que la pression fiscale est déjà la plus
élevée en france
bah vous posez vous posez une bonne
question c'est que l'emprunt comme tout
le monde devrait le savoir c'est de la
peau différé d'au classions les payer
comme sont des apprentis 3,3 latine mens
long terme
ceux qui devront payer c'est ceux qui ne
votent pas c'est à dire les enfants qui
sont année encore ce qu'on s'est un
petit peu intéressant comme idée mais
comme l'argent gratuit ça n'existe pas
malgré ce que les gens peuvent le croire
si vous de lâcher du pouvoir d'achat
dans l'économie qui n'a pas été gagnée
il ya quelqu'un qui va payer la
différence quoi c'est possible
un repas gratuit ça n'existe pas charles
gave est que pour le coup le
gouvernement avait d'autre choix que de
faire ça aujourd'hui
le choix est toujours le même c'est
beaucoup trop tard parce que la plupart
des entreprises en europe ont des fonds
propres est solide
la marge brute d'autofinancement des
entreprises françaises c'est à peu près
la moitié de ce qu'elle est pour
l'allemagne et vous pour la
grande-bretagne d'ordre quand vous avez
une entreprise anglaise une entreprise
allemand vous avez des fonds propres qui
vous permettent de
lire le choc là vous en avais pas je
n'avais pas parce que le gouvernement
veut à tout prix donc le gouvernement
maintenant vous donne de l'argent pour
prendre de choc mais c'est pas utile et
pop
il aurait mieux vaut ne pas commencer
par prendre d'argent et on aurait tous
beaucoup mieux donc ce qu'il faut c'est
simplement
alors elle forme de l'état sans vouloir
dire de méchant ce thème nous sommes
vraiment aujourd'hui
ou comme on l'a vu les hôpitaux ne
marchent pas la police ça marche pas
comme on le voit dans l'est en ce moment
l'armée c'est très moyen la diplomatie
il y en a plus l'enseignement national
n'en parlons plus et engrais pays plus
imposée du monde debout dit
tranquillement venir on va l'argent
surtout quand on sait d'où vient
l'argent c'est la seule crise du rapport
tente donc la seule en droit la seule
ressource qu'on peut sur un petit veau
aujourd'hui cette gaspillage étatique
il faut supprimer le gaspillage et tadic
pour rembourser tous les prêts qui ne
sont que la conséquence du gaspillage
étatiques alors justement finissons sur
ce prêt 40 milliards d'euros de prêts et
garanties par l'état en viala la bpi
accordés aux entreprises en difficulté
votre réaction nécessaire pas suffisant
ben s'il voulait c'est déjà somme c'est
déjà ça c'est mieux que rien mais si
vous croyez vous avez un problème de
troquer ponctuelle les entreprises sur
leurs aînés dans votre ponctualité un
problème de fond qui est l'absence de
rentabilité des entreprises françaises
la question voilà qu'elle entrait
répond-t-il qu'il faut faire pour
s'attaquer à l'absence de rentabilité
boucher un trou si un autre trou qui se
créent à côté c'est vraiment à
l'économie du sapeur camember vous savez
vous mettez vous faites un trop et
lorsque vous vous demandez ce que vous
mettez la terre alat il dit vous auriez
dû faire un trou pour mettre un terme à
ces c'est l'économie de
de bonneteau d'oborona donner car c'est
très bien mais ces gars en payant
d'abord c'est qu'une goutte dans le cinq
minutes à la mer et puis ensuite ça ne
règle en rien le problème de fond qui
est l'absence de rentabilité des
entreprises françaises aura compris il
faut une réforme totale du système et à
l'instant la bce qui annonce de
nouvelles mesures de soutien aux banques
cette fois-ci merci charles gave
présidence liberté d'avoir été avec nous
et les mesures de confinement sont
parfois plus difficiles dans certains
endroits que dans d'autres c'est le cas
notamment à petit qui dit plus de six
mois on s'en souvient après un incendie
de lusine lubrizol le site est en plein
nettoyage pourtant les riverains se dit
gêné par de fortes odeurs reportage sur
place aujourd'hui demoury avec pierre et
sa vie hivernaux comme des millions de
français
les habitants de l'agglomération
rouennaise sont confinés chez eux depuis
le 17 mars dernier l'entreprise lubrizol
a déjà commencé le nettoyage du site
mais voilà depuis qu'ils sont confinés
chez eux les riverains se plaignent
d'être incommodés par de fortes odeurs
ans lorsque les odeurs sont vraiment
très omniprésente cela crée des maux de
tête
cela crée des picotements au niveau de
la bouche
l'amendé des soucis de santé donc
l'urgence allait là c'est à dire que
pour ces personnes qui sont faibles
malade il faut absolument un plan
d'urgence faut absolument qu'elle puisse
sortir de ce périmètre d'odeurs ans n'a
droit qu'à un kilomètre aux alentours de
sortie sont toujours confrontés à ces
odeurs toxiques dans une lettre adressée
à la préfecture de seine maritime
l'association des sinistrés de lubrizol
demande des réponses et une action des
pouvoirs publics
certains voudraient suspendre les
travaux de nettoyage suspectée d'être à
la source des dernières nuisances
olfactives
un timing qui ne serait pas le bon selon
pierre andré durand préfet de seine
maritime
l'association dit des sinistrés de
lubrizol effectivement m'a écrit il ya
peu pour faire état d'odeurs qui était
tout à fait incommodante pour le pour le
voisinage
donc j'ai demandé à l'exploitant d'être
très attentif à ses procès cela ses
modes opératoires de nettoyage pour
faire en sorte que ces odeurs 10 minutes
pour être une idée de dire reporter ses
travaux à la sortie du confinement
je crains qu'elle ne soit contre
productive voit qu'elle soit peut être
même plus gênante parce que nous allons
aller vers de très fortes chaleurs et
plus il restera de matériaux sur le site
plus l'inconfort sera sera réelle du
côté de la justice l'instruction suit
actuellement son cours
l'odeur nauséabonde pourrait être une
nouvelle pièce ajoutée au dossier mettra
massardi qui défend l'association des
sinistrés de lubrizol insiste sur le
préjudice psychologique infligé aux
riverains avec le confinement s'est
beaucoup de personnes qui subissent les
odeurs et qui ont donc l'impression que
ils ne seront jamais reconnus dans leur
statut de victimes donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut continuer à se mobiliser je
le redis encore une fois parce que il ne
faut pas baisser les bras il faut faire
reconnaître ce statut alors qu'on a des
conséquences qui existe encore
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont majeurs quand on
peut pas aller dans son jardin parce que
il ya des odeurs qui sont trop présentes
qu'on a obligé de calfeutrer ses portes
pour être dans son domicile
c'est intolérable au sein de lubrizol le
nettoyage se poursuit les salariés de
l'entreprise en temps de retrouver le
cours d'une vie normale rapidement le
gros travail de fut donc a été fait déjà
ternie depuis elle quelques semaines et
là maintenant on passe à partie
nettoyage du terrain voilà tout se passe
bien d' équipe très compétente très bon
suivi tout se passe vraiment très bien
vraiment nous rien a déploré les travaux
de nettoyage sont donc maintenus sur le
site de lubrizol
plusieurs semaines seront encore
nécessaires avant un possible retour à
la normale d'ici là
riverains et salariés devront prendre
leur mal en patience
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
guillaume veste aux avocats bonsoir m
vsto merci d'être avec nous alors vous
connaissez bien ce dossier puisque vous
avez conseillé d'ailleurs gracieusement
aller roanne et lors de l' incendie de
de lubrizol vous suivez donc bien cette
affaire des habitants confiné mais très
gênée par ces odeurs nauséabondes vous
avez eu des témoignages depuis là-bas
jour 5 de gens à qui on croit sans doute
mais uniquement il ya des pins compte
des personnes qui a profité des
l on se souvient six mois après
l'incendié avec des habitants
traumatisés à l'époque ils sont
désormais en plein confinement avec le
stress que cela engendre d'autant plus
dure à supporter on imagine oui
j'imagine que cet acte a si bien qu'ils
ont continuellement au roi sans savoir
si c'est lui il faut savoir que a
signalé qu'il était bel et bien qu'ils
sont vivants
cette visite de toutes les autres taux
réglementés
on a été mené par une bande qui sont
habitués à avoir on a participé
l'industrie il était temps que je les
trouvais normal de base ils n'ont pas le
même mais il ya une telle que des
énergies à ce traumatisme électrifié
sortir rapidement qui brûle a des
conséquences
une dernière question parce que
malheureusement la liaison et les est
compliqué comme ça arrive parfois avec
un manque de réseau tout simplement
lubrizol qui n'explique pas non plus que
ces odeurs proviennent du voisin voisin
le transporteur normandie logistique
également touchées par les incendies
votre réaction savoir d'où viennent les
personnes merci guillaume veste aux
avocats désolé on est contraint
effectivement de couper cette liaison
qui est mauvaise merci en tout cas à
vous d'avoir été en direct
avec nous et le confinement qui
complique également la tâche des
travailleurs sociaux qui ne sont plus en
mesure d'accompagner physiquement les
populations vulnérables
à lyon nous avons rencontré tony silène
qui assistent en temps normal des
personnes qui souffrent d'isolement et
d'exclusion sociale
désormais l'essentiel de son travail se
fait au téléphone
luis carballo avec rania berrada tous
disent hélène et travailleur social
installé à lyon il est coordinateur d'un
j'aime un groupe d'entraidé mutuelle
en temps normal ils portent assistance à
plus de 70 personnes qui souffrent
d'isolement et d'exclusion sociale
depuis un peu plus d'un mois son groupe
a dû mettre fin aux sorties et à tous
types d'activités collectives
le travail de tony selene se résume
désormais un suivi quotidien des
adhérents aujourd'hui dell courbatures
ces comptes ont prouvé aujourd'hui
le travailleur social passent en moyenne
six heures par jour au téléphone
beaucoup des adhérentes du groupe
d'entraidé mutuelle souffre de troubles
psychologiques qui exacerbe le
confinement et l'isolément obligatoires
ces dernières semaines toni sailer a
remarqué une augmentation de l'anxiété
chez ses adhérents
il regrette que les responsables
politiques ne les rassure pas de volonté
d angoisse nous en fait on essaie de
trouver des supports en fait pour
essayer d'améliorer le quotidien des
gens l'ont ça devient
plus en plus difficile n'était plus le
confinement dure dans le temps plus cela
devient très très difficile mais en même
temps ça ne se passe pas qu'au niveau
des angoisses ya beaucoup de colère le
problème c'est les médias et les
politiques qui sont absolument pas
rassurante qui ont fait tomber la
pression qui ne se rend pas compte en
fait ya énormément de gens qui font
rassurer la situation veut que les gens
soient rassurés ce qui n'est absolument
pas le cas en france environ 350 gm ont
été créés en dix ans il regroupe plus de
quinze mille adhérents sur tout le
territoire
ce sont des espaces et des activités
pensée et organisée au quotidien par les
adhérents eux-mêmes avec l'aide
d'animateurs salariés et bénévoles
un principe rendu impossible par le
confinement qui brise cette chaîne de
solidarité elle ce sera la première
usine de fabrication de masques en
ile-de-france sa construction se fera en
un temps record quinze jours pour mettre
sur pied cette usine au blanc mesnil où
les ouvriers pourront confectionner
jusqu'à 500 mille masques par jour les
précisions de notre reporter et les
femmes au zoo c'est une véritable course
contre la montre qui vient de débuter
ici dans cet entrepôt où les ouvriers
travaillent sans relâche pour construire
une usine en l'espace de quelques jours
une usine où devraient être fabriquées
quotidiennement entre 400 à 500 mille
masques chirurgicaux
cette promesse vient d'un investisseur
chinois très attaché à la ville puisque
au début de l'épidémie il a offert dix
mille masques au personnel soignant et
aux agents communaux cette fois ci il a
décidé de passer à la vitesse supérieure
et ça risque d'aller très très vite je
propose écouter le maire du blanc-mesnil
c'est un monsieur qui a la foi est un
chef d'entreprise de grande qualité qui
est s'est fait tout seul mais c'est
également quelqu'un qui a un coeur qui
est un coeur énorme et qui avait qui
fait beaucoup pour la ville
donc on peut dire que les étoiles sont
alignées puisqu'on a à la fois
l'impulsion de la région
le financement de la région on a un
entrepreneur qui est capable de dire je
n'attends pas les financements publics
je mets mon argent pour que le projet
débute tout de suite
d'ailleurs les machines vont arriver
avant même que la salle blanche soit
terminé c'est à dire qu'on travaille
vrai
en parallèle on ne perd pas une seconde
l'idée c'est d'être prêt de commencer à
faire tourner les usines avant même le
début du dix confinement de manière à
servir la population moment du les
confinements qu'on ait commencé à
approvisionner en masse dès le début du
mois de mai quinze ouvriers
travailleront ici quotidiennement
lusine sera doté de trois machines de
fabrication
objectif être prêt à ravitailler toute
la région ile-de-france en masques pour
le déconfinement qui devrait débuter le
11 mai prochain
je répète il y avoir une cinquième nuit
de violences ce soir en banlieue
parisienne pour la quatrième fois
d'affilée des heurts ont opposé la nuit
dernière des habitants de plusieurs
quartiers sensibles aux forces de
l'ordre
by dans une école endommagé
partiellement à gennevilliers suite à un
incendie détention qui font suite à un
accident ce week-end impliquant un
manque un motard qui appelle au calme
d'ailleurs et une voiture de police
réaction du ministre de l'intérieur cet
après midi au sénat on écoute christophe
castaner ces dernières nuits vous l'avez
rappelé en particulier depuis samedi
soir des guets-apens ont été organisées
et là encore je vais vous dire que
d'abord nous les condamnons de la façon
la plus ferme et nous réagissons
immédiatement la nuit dernière une
quinzaine de faits se sont déroulés sur
le territoire national douze personnes
ont été interpellées depuis le week-end
dernier ce sont 28 qui ont été
interpellés le seul sénateur b
d'investigateurs n'ayez aucun doute nous
veillons à faire en sorte que le
confinement soit respectée partout en
france et partout nos forces de sécurité
intérieures sont mises en cause sont
provoquées nous leur devons protection
nous le faisons et nous devons
sanctionné cela de la façon la plus
ferme possible
oui l'homme blessé à moto à villeneuve
la garenne lui apporter plein depuis son
lit d'hôpital il a lancé un appel au
calme
j'ai appris qu'il y avait des cassages
vous avez cassé des voitures brûlées des
voitures je vous demande de rentrer chez
vous de vous calmer la justice sera bien
fait très cette question la crise
sanitaire va-t-elle mettre dans la rue
des centaines de milliers de locataires
c'est la crainte en tout cas de
nombreuses associations qui lance un
appel à suspendre les paiements de
loyers sur l'ensemble du territoire
jusqu'au 11 mai objectif affiché sa
solidarité avec ses locataires en
difficulté durant la période de
confinement est interpellé gouvernent
man pour mettre en place de nouvelles
mesures dead nadège abderrazak mon
classeur de factures et donc bah voila
j'ai là c'est le joaillier qui est de
après j'ai en dessous d'un en fait j'ai
ma cotisation
edf où je paye 115 euros par mois et
puis après j'ai d'autres factures
également bien sûr aux téléphones
mutuelle assurance auto les factures
continuent de tomber et malgré
l'installation du confinement
céline gestionnaire dans un centre de
formation de secourisme a été placés au
chômage partiel
elle a perdu un tiers de son salaire
avec désormais 1000 euros de revenus
mensuels
elle se demande si elle va bien pouvoir
payer sa plus grande dépense à savoir
son loyer de 650 euros
si on touche pas de salaire on peut pas
payer toutes les charges et après on se
retrouve en endettement alors que c'est
pas de notre fait à l'incitation ça sera
des comme ce que les gens vivent déjà
pour certains c'était de plus avoir
assez d'argent tout simplement pourra
assurer toutes les charges
ce qu'il faut payer toutes les charges
qui sont très importantes et il est
encore une fois ce que je pense c'est
que on demande des efforts à tout le
monde et donc c'est passé ça serait
logique qu'il que bah voilà cuillère
suspension des loyers pendant la période
du confinement et même à la limite au
delà le temps que ledit une reprise de
l'activité depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
des voix s'élèvent pour demander des
mesures des deux locataires
l'association droit au logement invite
l'état à s'inspirer de ses voisins et à
mettre en place un moratoire sur les
loyers chômage partiel voyez partiel 0
revenu 0 loyer c'est ça qu'il faut
mettre en place aujourd'hui pour les
locataires parce que les gens sont
angoissés comment ils vont faire la fin
du mois il ya plein de pays qu'ont
compris des mesures enfin je veux dire
d'espagne suspend le paiement des loyers
pendant trois mois et met en place une
baisse des loyers une baisse de la dette
de 50 % d'office
l'allemagne également suspendre
l'obligation de payer loyer et étale le
paiement des loyers sur deux ans voilà
on a un centre de pays qu'ils prennent
des mesures
il y en a plein d'autres dire qu'ils
prennent des mesures en direction des
locataires des habitants pour pas qu'ils
se retrouvent à la rue
maintenant il faut que le gouvernement
prenne unis une loi qui institue un
moratoire des loyers sur les loyers sont
suspendus vous êtes où les loyers s'ils
sont pas payés ne donnent pas lieu à des
sanctions contre des locataires d'une
part d'autre part la mise en place d'un
fonds de plusieurs milliards d'euros
l'institution des recherches économiques
et sociales estime que plus de deux
millions cinq cent mille ménages
connaissent actuellement des difficultés
pour payer leur loyer ou leur prêt
immobilier pour l'heure le gouvernement
ne prévoit ni suspension ni report du
paiement des loyers
les expulsions locatives sont justes
interdite jusqu'au 31 mai et c'est la
fin de cette émission vous le savez un
peu écourtée en raison de la crise du
corps navires us ce qui nous pousse nous
aussi à nous adapter prochain point
complet sur l'actualité ce sera demain
matin 8h heure française excellent de
fin de soirée at-on su rt france
[Musique]
depuis le début tu écris des français
sont dans le flou avec des informations
contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique
très très fortes notamment pour pour les
actifs bien évidemment plus vous êtes
âgé plus vous avez peur du réel de la
mort c'est évident ses études elle
montre que weepu rate rent a car